alright guys we only have one night to
finish up this Harry Potter if so just
for the focus get it done I'm going to
be out of the office of it so uh do you
like Harry Potter yeah yeah yeah I'm
totally married but er yeah
Harry Potter is great and you wizards
they're so cool
what's your favorite part when they're
playing quail ball oh yeah I love that
part what's your favorite moment I love
when uh Harry shoots his wand Harry
Potter shoots the one yeah when he kills
a Bulbasaur oldest or yeah yeah it's so
good I was so happy though that Volda
Sora was actually good in the end
yeah yeah yeah george RR martin it
catchphrase he'd always be like no in my
house you got took all the gold went
back to the dumble dome I liked when
Harry Potter there was that other little
o da [ __ ]
Oh gahbage yeah and what is your
favorite line that Harry Potter just
says I was King Day yeah remember when
his mom was like Harry yeah Harry Harry
Potter yeah but Harry wands don't kill
Wizards wizards kill Wizards I'm glad
that it's a modern movie with a real
happy ending totally with Hermione and
Harry Harry Potter getting or together
yeah when he almost got with Peeta Peeta
yeah yeah it is always taking his shirt
off turning into a wolf and I'm like I
don't want to end up with that guy yeah
I get he's like a protector like he
loves you but like no yeah yeah so you
haven't seen Harry Potter huh yeah yeah
it did you oh absolutely not
okay
you